ces problèmes il est que c'est toujours
difficile de ne pas dire que du bien de
quelqu'un qui est en difficulté
actuellement qui souffre d'un cancer
mais en même temps c'est vrai qu'il faut
se remettre en tête que ça a été un des
premiers présidents de clubs à être un
briquet dans des affaires de corruption
tout le monde se souvient d'un fameux
match om valenciennes 10 à sais plus
combien d'années les années 80 et 100 95
95 93 7 ans 95 qu'il a été condamné
je savais bien qu'il fallait pas que non
donc donc c'est c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui a introduit l'idée de
corruption dans le nom est oui alors ils
ont peur dans l'est pourtant regardez la
cote d'amour est légal il très bien
c'est un cétacé tain c'est un peu c'est
un par leur cellule et celle de jean luc
mélenchon du football je veux dire c'est
quelqu'un qui sait conquérir les raisons
il faut parler des chefs d'entreprises
qui sont très importantes dans le milieu
du sport mais ils peuvent aussi
dénaturer le sport je veux dire en
termes par exemple dans le rugby par
exemple des messieurs comme boudjellal
ou altrad dénature le rugby le rugby
n'était pas un sport c'était une façon
d'être et ils y ont introduit le
professionnalisme qui dénaturent ils ont
été ils ont été les garants quand même
de l'introduction du professionnalisme
ils sont en train de transformer le
rugby qui était une façon d'être en un
sport comme les autres et d'ailleurs on
est obligé on est en ce moment de former
des joueurs de rugby tel qu'on a formé
des joueurs de football
c'est à dire des milliardaires
analphabètes et ça c'est un danger je
veux dire c'est très important des chefs
d'entreprise dans le sport mais
attention de ne pas introduire trop
d'éléments de l'entreprise de garder
quelque chose aux sports qui vient
d'ailleurs qui vient de la région où on
habille de la région qu'on leur présente
et c'est alors c'est peut-être une
vision réactionnaire ou ou passéiste et
sur la droite daniel bilalian